[Music]
as we previously reported those
responsible for shazam 2 recently posted
the first teaser in which you can marvel
at the revamped outfit of the eponymous
superhero
now director david f sandberg added an
image of the most important characters
since monday you get to see the total of
6 superheroes in full costume on twitter
hence it is also clear not only does
lead actor billy batson get a visually
redesigned look as a superhero
but so do his companions overall the
outfit looks simpler less padded and
just trendier
this is especially evident in a direct
comparison further news is michelle
both's plan role is merry as she will be
replaced by fellow actress grace fulton
unlike freddy
darla eugene pedro and billy director
sandberg also confirmed this on twitter
where it was also revealed that she will
embody both a human mary as well as her
counterpart as a superhero
unfortunately we will have to wait a
little longer for the great battle
between the teenagers and the three
daughters of the titan atlas because
shazam
fury of the gods is not expected to be
released before june 2nd
2023 hardly any other coming-of-age
series stands for the charm of the 80s
like stranger things
the hit production which was initially
released in 2017
is now looking forward to its fourth
season and four new cast members are not
to be kept from the fans
the most familiar face is certainly emmy
beth mcnulty who played the main
character in the canadian drama series
and with an e
in the fourth season she will become
vicky who has both a chill and a nerdy
side
and according to the description later
falls in love with one of the main
characters
alongside her 19 year old miles strude
who embodies the increasingly unstable
basketball star patrick makes his debut
in the series
cheerleader chrissy who will be played
by grace van dine is also set to be
introduced in the upcoming season
at first sight she seems as good as
perfect but is said to hide a dark
secret
behind her innocent facade last but not
least in addition to the three teens
there's also a new guidance counselor
coming to the hawkins high school namely
miss kelly
this role is played by hawaiian regina
ting chen
serious star david harbour was also
surprisingly talkative on the talk show
jimmy kimmel life
there he expressed his regret for the
fact that the production and the current
status are being kept from the fans so
that they don't find out anything before
the official start
however he did count to that by sharing
a few details
based on his statement filming is still
in progress and we can expect it to come
to a close around
august in the event of delays new
episodes would be released at the end of
the year at the earliest
especially considering how complex the
post-production of the series is
colleagues finn wolford and gate
madarazzo share a similar opinion as the
former in particular already announced
in the past
that he doesn't expect season 4 to start
any earlier than 2022
in any case we are excited to see
whether the rest of the shooting will
proceed as planned and we will of course
keep you
updated on the release date of stranger
things season 4.
on wednesday paramount pictures and
hasbro studios
finally announced the official title of
the upcoming 7th transformers movie in a
virtual conference
it will be called transformers rise of
the beasts and following the moderate
success of transformers
last night it'll breathe new life into
the franchise
meanwhile it's been three years since
the spin of bumblebee was released which
was well received but failed to generate
above average profits
all the more pleasing that producer
lorenzo de bueno ventura and director
stephen cabell jr have revealed a few
more details about the seventh part
which will be out next year
what is known is that the maximals
terracons and predacons fractions will
appear alongside the autobots and
decepticons
the former can transform not only into
vehicles but even into animal forms and
thus give the protagonist
a much harder time fans can expect
appearances by optimus prime mirage
rhinox eraser optimus primal as well as
the two female representatives archie
and nightbird
the story is set to be set in 1994
primarily in new york city and brooklyn
nearly 13 years after the storyline of
bumblebee
coincidentally the spin of starring
hayley steinfeld is also the predecessor
of rise of the beasts in terms of
content
the main villain is the terracon's
leader scorers who together with his
companions poses the greatest threat to
optimus and the team
we look forward to more information on
transformers rise of the beasts
and eagerly await its release in almost
exactly one year on june 24th
2022 we've known for a while that the
upcoming the flash
won't just have one or two superheroes
of its leaf in addition to the returning
barry allen alias the flash and the two
batman ben affleck and michael keaton
many fans are looking forward to the
newcomer sasha cali who will be
appearing as supergirl for the first
time
in keeping with his director andy
musgetty posted their first photo of the
superheroine's outfit on instagram some
days ago
you don't have to be a dc expert to
notice the color parallels to henry
cavill suit not only that but the
s-shaped symbol
on the chest which of course has nothing
to do with the actual ladder has only
been
marginally altered all of this could
indicate that their family relationship
of being cousins
is now thematized in the film and not
just in the comics
a further sign of this is the empty
cryogenic path that superman finds in
man of steel
and in which supergirl ought to be
however this is contradicted by the fact
that dc and warner have actually
concluded with the zack snyder movies
like for example man of steel
and do not want to continue them
thematically as you can see there are
still some unanswered questions
regarding the upcoming dc multiverse
spectacle
which unfortunately won't be clarified
anytime soon
the flash is expected to be released in
theaters on november 4th
2022 as
has been known for a few days a sequel
to 2020 scoop is set to be produced
with box office takings of just 26.3
million the proceeding film did not even
reach its budget of 90 million though
that was mainly due to the pandemic and
the fact that most movie theaters were
closed
the third film with the scooby-doo and
his pals nevertheless managed to bring a
refreshing
3d animated film to cinemas and home
theaters almost 16 years after
scooby-doo ii monsters unleashed despite
the fact that many die hard fans were
bothered about the many new elements
yet a further contributing factor is the
hanna-barbera multiverse that was
introduced in the film which
with its abundance of characters whether
the appetite for further sequels or
spin-offs
this is probably why warner took the
bold step of sticking with a franchise
in spite of red figures and supplying
fans with new content
according to director tony savoni who
was interviewed by comicbookmovie.com
the crew of the first part is back and
working on a sequel to scoop
however at the same time he pointed out
that it has not yet been officially
announced by warner
regarding the release date stevonnie
didn't want to or couldn't reveal
anything yet but considering the
circumstances
we expect warner to make an announcement
soon
last year disney announced several new
star wars projects at its big investor
day
among those is the anime series star
wars visions
about which for a long time nothing new
had been reported
fortunately that has now changed as
lucasfilm officially announced that the
anthology
is going to be presented during a 30
minute panel at the digital anime expo
light
besides a sneak preview you can of
course look forward to a various special
guests commenting on and following star
wars visions at the beginning of july
among them are executive producers james
road jackie lopez and josh rhymes who
will at least virtually join
anime producer kanako shirasaki and
co-producer justin leech
content-wise information is still scarce
so far all we really know is that the
project will consist of several short
films we'll definitely keep you posted
on the panel and look forward to
revealing more about star wars visions
very soon
we can even expect a release this year
on disney plus
soon the hotel transylvania series will
come to an end as the fourth and final
part is slowly approaching
although as a few days ago this is no
longer quite accurate since the
responsible parties officially reported
that the movie will not be released at
the end of july
but rather in october in regards to
content you can be prepared for a crazy
farewell with the main characters
dracula
jonathan frankenstein and wayne still
having an exciting adventure ahead of
them
due to the monstrification ray dracula
and the rest turn to humans whereas
johnny turns into a monster the former
monsters don't seem to like the new
human state that much which is why they
search all over the world to find a cure
whether they manage to return to their
old strength or whether dracula must
continue to live on as an
ordinary mortal is something you will be
able to find out in theaters
starting october 1st 2021
disney's live action film campaign
continues as deadline report last
wednesday an actress has finally been
found for the snow wildlife action film
adaption
we're talking about rachel zagler who's
about to make the leap from newcomer to
hollywood great
not only did the 20 year old play the
lead character in steven spielberg's
west side story but she also snacked a
role in the upcoming shazam
fury of the gods in addition to her
acting talent her singing voice must
also have been a reason for the
commitment as the multi-talented actress
has been wowing fans of her youtube
channel for
years with cover versions of well-known
songs the soundtrack is supposed to be
the main emphasis of the live-action
film anyway
just like the original from 1937 benji
passage and justin paul who already said
the right tone in la la land have been
entrusted with the music
expectations for snow white have
therefore been raised considerably and
we can most probably look forward to a
release as early as 2022
[Music]